from usa today
officers in california
saved a pilot who crashed onto uh the
railroad tracks seconds before a train
smashed the wreckage into pieces
on sunday a cessna
172 made an emergency landing around 2pm
shortly after takeoff from
whiteman airport according to the
associated press and then landed right
on the train tracks as a train was
coming two officers from the la police
department can be seen on body camera
footage pulling the bloodied pilot to
safety moments before the train collided
with the aircraft
that is not an overly dramatic
description that's actually what
happened we have the footage here let's
watch uh this footage real quick
okay so you can see them
this guy's right on the plane train
tracks
yeah got looks like four officers there
they're taking their lives into their
hands because
and then
[Music]
there you go so i think you could count
about five seconds
that is something right out of a movie
right there you count about five seconds
they had
and they could have still
you know even clearing it after five
seconds it could have been debris that
they hit them or anything so they were
taking their lives in their hands
to save a complete stranger
and i think that's it's it's worth
pointing to this video for i think three
reasons number one it's just an
incredible video
uh number two this is a great example of
actual heroism in a culture where
the term heroism you know heroic
courageous all these terms are so often
misused and abused and misappropriated
and we use it to describe
um
you know a teacher who comes out as
non-binary to her sixth grade
students that's always heroic
no
that's
creepy this is actually what heroism
looks like
you're making a sacrifice number one
um
and you're putting yourself
in danger in some kind of danger doesn't
always have to be physical danger to be
heroic could be you know you could be
taking uh you know intellectual risks or
it could be something like that but
you're taking a real risk for the sake
of someone else that's what courage and
heroism looks like
and the third reason to bring it up
is um you look at that video and you say
is so are we still defunding the police
is that still an idea
we're gonna send the social workers in
to do that
was the last time you met a social
worker who would do that
a team of uh social workers guidance
counselors therapists
i tell you what we defund the police and
we send the uh the squad of therapists
and guidance counselors in
they're gonna stand off at a safe
distance
and counsel that guy in the plane so
that he feels better about the fact that
he's about to get pancaked by a train
so they're gonna provide him mental
they're going to focus on on
you know
helping him in his mental health
in the five seconds before he dies
now the reason you need cops is that you
need actual people to go into these
situations
and do what uh
most people are not willing to do
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends